hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well as a
philosophical school the stoics handsome
quite definite views nature the
existence the workings of the divine and
love the relation of the human being to
the divine and is covered a lot of
ground including things like you know
should we engage in divination and it's
divination true or is it you know going
to yield us reliable results you know in
this hand connections with larger
metaphysical issues about the freedom
and determinism and fate we're really
quite so much about them because
epictetus himself is not particularly
concerned with those sorts of questions
instead he's much more interested as we
see him in how should the human being
understand him or herself and other
human beings in relation to God and how
should even being comport him or herself
in relation to God on that basis so what
is what is the central question for
equities the really key question is
understanding the nature of the human
being and that was going to involve
understanding the nature of God along
the way in part because human beings of
God are not radically total
a separate from each other that heart of
his his important perspective we are not
of course the same thing as a God from
the stoic perspective but we are in some
way connected with god and in a way that
very enough strongly asserts human
dignity not only the human dignity of
the individual human being Hussein is
reading stoic philosophy but of all
human beings so if we look at 2.8 which
is really one of the central places to
go for this he begins with this
discussion of the good and he says you
know what can we actually say a battle
that good God is helpful but the good
also is helpful it would seem there for
the true nature that good will be found
where we find that of God to be so what
is the true nature of God flush far from
it land far from it fame far from it
it's not these material things although
God of course you know in the stomach
cosmology if we want to be very
technical about it is in fact material
God is running throughout the the whole
love you can say creationists that's the
whole of the cosmos the universe but
what is God intelligence knowledge right
a reason so he says this is where you
should seek the true nature of the good
so where do you look for do you look for
in a plant no in an irrational creature
No so that if you seek it in that which
is rational why do you keep on seeking
it somewhere else then in that which
differentiates the rational from the
irrational what is it that makes us
rational as opposed to irrational we are
partly both you realize you know from
the stomach perspective there is an
animal nature which we have that you
know in
it unites us with the other animal so
it's connected with our bodily
Constitution and all these other things
but we have something that exceeds that
something that goes beyond that
something that gives us a higher degree
of being which renders us like or if we
want to be very literal part of the
divine so we going to say we're not
going to find it in irrational echar una
fight it in human nature he'll tell us
we are actually fragments or parts of
God this is a quite revolutionary thing
to say for the stoics it's not just that
the human being can be connected with
God or somehow participate in god we are
portions of the divinity not then that
should go to our heads and make us think
too highly of ourselves that's actually
going to as we see a little bit later
it's a reason for some caution but we
are fragments of God or another way of
saying this is we have God we have the
divine within us within our very selves
and where do we have them in our Faculty
of reason that is the portion of
ourselves that God providentially gave
to us so that we could develop it God
also gave us other things to enter
sexual impulses so we can reproduce are
you know appetite so that we can make
sure that we eat stuff so this body
doesn't die all those other things
Faculty of locomotion which by the way I
have been used to write on the
chalkboard right so that can serve some
good purposes but where we where we see
the divine in ourselves is in our
faculty of rationality and also you know
since it's the same thing in our faculty
of choice insofar as those things are
screwed up at muddy and disordered at
Madame poorly oriented we have taken the
bit of God within ourselves and screwed
we have obscured it it isn't quite use
the notion of the image of God that we
will see play an important role and
other theologies but you can see epic to
is doing something similar to that so
what are some of the implications of
this he says will you not therefore seek
the true nature of the good and that
quality the lack of which in all
creatures other the man prevents you
from using their good of any of these
what is that you are being a primary
importance why then are you ignorant of
your own kinship why do you not know the
source from which you have sprung will
you not appear in mind whatever you eat
who you are that eat and whom you are
nourishing this really places things in
a different perspective you know we
sometimes safer for you know pregnant
women oh you're eating for two or I
suppose if you have twins for three or
triplets for four or whatever right
we're doing this all the time because
we're carrying with it ourselves this is
part of God and so you know when we're
thinking about who are we eating four
and the meal that we put in front of us
and how its arranged and whether we're
going to go have seconds or whether we
you know restrain ourselves and little
you know slow ourselves down and savor
the veal perhaps or any of these sorts
of things we want to be considering that
word you might say taking catalogue for
the ride within ourselves he goes on
further whenever you engage in
intercourse with women or women you know
with men who are you then do this
whenever you mix in society when you
ever you take physical exercise whenever
you converse do you not know that you
are nourishing God exercising god you
are bearing God about within you you
poor wretch and you don't know it do you
think I'm speaking of some external God
made a silver or gold it's within
yourself that you bury him and you do
not perceive here's where it gets a
little bit tough to hear right you do
not perceive that you're defiling God
with impure thoughts and filthy actions
in the presence of an image of God you
wouldn't dare to do any of the things
do it but when God Himself is present
within you seeing and hearing everything
are you not ashamed to be thinking of
doing such things as these so you know
this is a very important thing to keep
in mind as far as epictetus is concerned
we are parts of God God is within us we
are involving the divine in whatever it
is that we do through our choices
through the very faculty that makes us
in a certain sense divine so the
question is what kind of God are we
actually you know working on or or
developing what are we doing with the
part that we've been get up screwing it
up in 1.9 he also talks about the divine
community we are hearts on a sort of
divine common law I'm going to talk
about this a little bit more in another
video on the the whole notion of stoic
cosmopolitanism but this is an important
point he says that that media are part
of a community of gods and humans by
God's there he doesn't mean you know God
is the entire thing that runs the
universe but you might say divine powers
that are dad you tised into you know
making things happen this is another
thing that the Stoics did in fact we'll
leave it in and they thought that there
was god with a capital G and then
there's you know God's on but we are in
a community with them if we choose to be
if we decide to be rational if we do the
work that's required so this is offering
a quite an opportunity to human beings a
little bit later in chapter 13 you know
there's this question how may we do
things so that they're acceptable to the
gods how can we be part of this divine
community in the best way so somebody
asked him how it's possible to eat
except ibly to the gods interesting
question right
again let me see it's not just in going
to church it's or temple or whatever
it's not just in burning incense it's
not just in like meditating by yourself
and having good thoughts it's in the
day-to-day processes by which we work we
you know continue and orient our lives I
probably share with other people as well
and are involved in a larger economy
that we live out our relation to the
divine so somebody says how can I do
that when I'm eating and Epictetus says
if it's done justly and graciously the
word gracious there's translating it
would know me it would all me knows
which you know could he have the sense
of thoughtfully in a way that you know
takes into account everybody else that's
involved listen I'll get back to that a
moment fairly eso's restrained italy and
decently it's being done acceptable in
to the guys so how would this take form
well he has an example here that will
come back to you but he has another set
of examples that come up that are quite
funny epictetus says you ought to think
of yourself as being at a banquet you
know when things come to you if you're
in a gathering are you going to be the
slob who is just you know taking stuff
willy-nilly in a selfish way or do you
take your bit of it and then let the
dish pass on don't like hold on to it
and keep spooning it onto your plate
this is a big common problem not only in
our own day with dinner parties but back
in ancient times as well because it's
part of damaged human nature you can say
the tendency to do this or the thing you
know to take the best of the dish for
oneself and leave it for other people
that would not be fair that would not be
just that would not be gracious right
there would not be restrained so that's
part of it another thing that he brings
up this is something well worth keeping
in mind when you're dining
restaurant when you've asked for warm
water and the servant doesn't heed you
or if he does hit you but brings in
tepid water or if he's not even to be
found in the house then to refrain from
anger and not explode is this not
acceptable to the Goths this is a way in
which we can honor the God within us as
part of the larger you know whole scope
of the day ad that's that's involved in
this divine community and it's a way
that we can relate ourselves to God in
the other person who we don't have to
treat as just being something there to
trust a dominate for us to get what we
want out of and then to become angry if
they don't do precisely what it is that
we wish them to do and Epictetus reminds
us the fellow human beings even if
they're slaves even if they're people
who you know in the ancient world
because they don't count for much even
if you think that we're better than them
which from a stoic perspective is
actually wrong they are equally children
they're equally parts of their equally
derived from and contain within
themselves God so this place is quite a
responsibility upon us we want to
recognize according to the stoic
doctrine that other people are also
equally like us parts of God and
children of God he uses that very
language that were much more used to
seeing in a Christian context culturally
the stoics took this you know in with
respect to epictetus quite far so you
know what should our general orientation
to God me it's not so much about prayer
although you know things like
thankfulness are just fine according to
epictetus and actually a sign of being
on the right path it has much more to do
with our actions and how we conceive of
ourselves and how we can see with others
and how we think of ourselves and others
as being part of this divine
Commonwealth that comprises ever
rational creature in the world